[Applause]
Joe looks like the type of guy that
would say fudge instead of he also
looks like the type of guy who would eat
fudge instead of he's right I enjoy
fine Sam once tweeted that the worst
thing you can say about a comedian on
stage is that he's a nice person that's
not true
when Sam's on stage I say he's a
terrible person he's not funny and I
hope he dies slowly that was a good one
spaz Bono and I remember when I first
met Joe it was right after Geppetto
turned him into a real boy
[Music]
[Applause]
Sam's allergic to ibuprofen
it's his kryptonite that's not the only
thing he has in common with Superman
both of their fathers abandon them Joe
you look like pee-wee Herman if his big
adventure was going to Dunkin Donuts
[Applause]
[Music]
like I could stand to lose a few pounds
did you know that Sam suffers from
terrible AGD it's actually a blessing
though he can't focus on his upbringing
his love life in his career Joe look at
that belly you put the burgers and ass
burgers
Sam used to tutor young children for
money but their books had words he'd
never seen before like taste
last joke it's hard for Joe to be mean
cuz he's a good devout Catholic you know
Joe was so Catholic that he actually
looks like a pregnant virgin
[Applause]
Comedy Central gave Sam an hour special
they'll do anything to make the Daily
Show look funny first year for Sam to
get laughs they'll have to be an hour of
him trying to lift weights
[Applause]